guys everybody loves a dynasty from
fanatic tube sk-gaming right up to
Astralis having strong consistent
champions is good for eSports but this
is counter-strike and in CS nothing is
guaranteed that's why the best team in
the world can lose to a squad of
underdogs who just wanted more we're
here to talk about that David's who
defeated their Goliath who made history
who shocked the world who pissed off a
lot of fanboys we're here to count down
the top 10 most shocking upsets in csgo
starting us off is LG's incredible upset
over na'vi at the grand finals of the
MLG columbus major this is really
frightening right now
na'vi could lose the most horrible way
possible he's gonna go for the spray
that's a head shot instead from coldzera
Zeus dropping the form once they need a
lot more right now Infinix gonna pick up
the kill edward trying to deny it 15
seconds left they're all the Molotov
raining into CT spawn instead and now
Guardian is finally here with the AWP 10
seconds Edward II did it once for this
time the form it is going to be going
down to the last second top we're gonna
get in and it would have to cross it
again it's our wanted me too
they've got almost no help he get
definitely do this looks of the shot he
gets the one
now remember guys once upon a time the
Brazilian dynasty was just a group of up
and comers looking to prove that Brazil
could make an impact in cs:go making it
all the way to the grand finals was
impressive enough and Navi after all
were back-to-back major finalists so
everybody figured LG were done at that
point but they couldn't have been more
wrong and now it is a one on two taco
look at the see finger close it out here
and win it for the Brazilians it's gonna
be a big turn around there hits that
shuttle soos an ounce of one-on-one
Guardian versus taco it may just be
destined to fade with that win LG made
history they became the first team
outside of Europe to win a major and
began their reign of dominance taking
the number 9 spot on our list is a
victory that nobody saw coming
it's tyloo vs. LG at dreamhack Masters
Malmo 2016 look at the position inside
mid right now DD catches off FNX this is
down to one player for LG at coldzera
the MVP from the major he's got the
first one found second as well but the
bomb still planted he's got big work to
do with no kit the sequel not a flag did
somebody flanked it tie lose got map one
against LG who would've thought Ty Lee
that complete underdogs of this
tournament just taking the first map and
the best of three
I can't zoom in asti gaming here now
China isn't really known for being a
csgo powerhouse and like we just told
you Brazil was on the rise coming in hot
off a major victory so when the 50th
ranked team in the world took on the
most recent major champions and a
best-of-three elimination match the
outcome seemed obvious right he's not
gonna rotate then library hits another
great shot on fur in the air and it's a
two-man advantage Tyler make it down
with three man Phenix he's got to get
one more back he's got a rise from the
ashes like the Phoenix that he claims to
be but he's caught the open at tyloo and
that's it the major champions being
knocked out by one of the biggest
underdogs of this tournament no one
after he expected him to even get out
the group stages better knows me
knocking these guys out that's
absolutely nuts
at number eight is cloud nine
astonishing victory over the Brazilian
juggernauts sk-gaming on their own turf
at the season 4 Pro League finals in
South Paulo Brazil
despite topping the n/a League nobody
expected the boys from c9 to even be a
challenge for the undisputed best team
in the world at the time he wants to go
all the way too long in this which could
catch them off they've got a drop
through another one thing about dropping
through they could push to P as a result
they want to contest's to e who gets one
it's called zero bomb down automatic in
a one versus one he's got no idea where
automatic is he's rotated all the way
too long and cold might get caught he's
looking down toward the Tories in the
open automatic to give cloud9 season 4
but c9 upset the tournament favourites
even in front of an entire arena full of
screaming Brazilian fans normally the
crowd erupts when a team wins a
tournament
that's quite a hollow victory there
considering the atmosphere obviously we
have SK gaming that's so heartbreaking
but they are your season four champions
number 7 on our list is Vega squadron
decimating n IP and eliminating them
from the illegal anti major qualifiers
now look when you think of ninjas in
pyjamas you think of one of the most
legendary teams to ever touch the game
you think of dominance you probably
don't think about them getting dumped
stirred by a CIS roster you've barely
heard of the shadow that does have a
real opportunity hate goes for a quick
reload just about has time for that
as in comes both Shanda how does he get
that one one versus two exists as well
taking critical damage not for any kills
the very telegraph to play and it's
looking worse and worse this just exists
now against five players for Vega
squadron and it's all over
Vega squadron will eliminate ni P Vega
squadron didn't just upset ninjas in
pyjamas that day they eliminated them
marking the first time that team ever
missed a major
[Music]
coming in at number six is ences
incredible run at the 2019 cata beats a
major after clawing their way through
the EU closed qualifiers just to get to
the tournament nobody thought this
ragtag group of finns could do anything
on counterstrikes biggest stage but
these underdogs were on a mission to
ruin everybody's pickups 32 kills to his
name this could be all she wrote 20
seconds left come the semi-finals the
Finns push past simple and na'vi in a
grueling 2-1 victory you don't want to
be that
[Applause]
Susan
Zuse the deep breath you got one with
damping but really dead what with Navi
that's what he's wanted he went back for
a reason but the ends had made it all
the way to the grand finals of a major
eliminating some of the world's best
teams along the way and although they
were humbled by a straw las' will never
forget how easy it was for ents marking
the halfway point in our list is gambit
Cinderella story win at the 2017 pgl
Cracow major gambit had made a
remarkable run but nobody thought they
could make it through the semi-finals
where they were up against the reigning
major champions a straw --less they were
a misfit group of CIS players that no
one expected to contend for a major
championship but Zeus promised the world
he'd win a [ __ ] major
inspiration for gamba kya he pulls into
the open but the smoke will save him
just in time but I'm trying to get that
girl and she cracks it bounds here for
gambit and sea monster in another head
spotted another head shots it's rain
doing great work so
now just Dupree definitely know where he
is grenades additional when a sailing in
authority you still could actually get
caught in the back it sees but it looks
like they don't even know if it's gonna
be be thick or fast they're going back
to a device has to punch one versus
three with justice Scouts a trend mo and
hobby with all the time in the world to
position hobbits
sitting there in connector eight
dangerous positions device knows to look
out for it missus
gave it triumphed and defeated their
toughest opponent of the tournament when
everyone had written them off and in the
grand finals they won the battle of the
underdogs capping off a truly incredible
upset at the eleague season 2 finals
optic gaming stunned fans across the
world with their victory over Astralis
in a true David versus Goliath contest
and that upset is coming in at number 4
on our list nobody expected this na team
to even make it out of groups let alone
to the grand finals so when they cruise
past no sports and faze clan in the
quarters and semies to meet a straw
Louis everybody thought it had to be a
fluke right wrong straight through
standing over to spray not connecting
just doing a bit of damage here and
there but do you see anything that's why
the easy shot for him and that drops the
ball heavy should have been putting it
down now for the triple the hero of
optic gaming goes for the spray catches
the free perfectly follows up with that
stuff on sip leaks this guy in the grand
finals 34 kills now he just sees another
couple and they will have that trophy
it's gonna be Caribbean clave left with
over a minute but in a 2-1 for spray
comes through rush gets a kill and
ladies and gentlemen up take a knee
of a league seasons home optic did the
impossible improve all of their doubters
wrong coming in at number three is
complexities inconceivable upset over
Danish powerhouses stralla s-- at the
blast premier spring series 2020 let us
paint you a picture here Astralis were
the undisputed number one team in the
world
the reigning four-time major champions
and arguably the best team to ever play
csgo complexity on the other hand well
they were ranked 44th in the world and
hadn't exactly impressed lately but when
the two faced off in the upper bracket
of the group stage things did not go as
everyone predicted an Oakland one bus is
true that's almost unwinnable he's gonna
stand up for a killer oh my god it
sounds around for it an unbelievable
race to middle they know they are
knowing catwalk they're gonna take the
fight right away and come fake well then
the potting head shop taking down
divisive and he'll follow it up taking
down to free Hill last thing is perfect
he's blind in return and Russia's gonna
try and hold the line there's flames
everywhere he's got a triple kill poison
is gonna close things out map one is
gonna go to complexities of an issue
there but let's see if they can actually
then one of these grenades it's gonna be
a bit early so they're not waiting oh
it's a double Oh we'll take our mega
skin claim and that shorty shocks them
they win the round somehow what a
turnaround it might not matter
Oh Magus he had to help for it but now
he's been taken out and sip just trying
to buy time flanking around bravery runs
him down sixteen and row
in the unlikeliest of outcomes
complexity trounced a straw list for one
of the greatest upsets ever witnessed in
csgo
and silenced their critics taking the
runner-up spot on our list is cloud
nines legendary win at the Boston e
League Major as you probably gathered at
this point na was the laughingstock of
CS for years so when cloud 9 found
themselves against tournament favorites
faze clan the grand finals of a major it
seemed like the dream run was over this
is the final boss this is the face
roster just look at this talent it is so
stuck cuz we look at meetings this yet
when they played each other you can see
cloud 9 have certainly not had the best
of it phase clients seem to be that
kryptonite but cloud 9 persevered
taking it all the way to a third map and
well by now you know the rest he's good
Juiz on inside but look at the time look
at this
[Applause]
can make the play just by saying that oh
do you know what that noise means that
it means it's match point cloud nine the
sort from this position before he cannot
miss a single shot Guardian waits
patiently as cloud my scepter push up
Oh
[Applause]
taking the number-one spot on our list
is the Battle of the Danes its North's
impossible victory not once but twice
over you guessed it a straw --less at
Dreamhack master Stockholm 2018 you've
heard us eight a million times a few of
them just on this list alone but
Astralis are a very good csgo team after
winning six of their last nine
tournaments they looked unstoppable
so when North beat a straws in a bo3
during the group stage many thought it
was just dumb luck and this is nothing
short of historic victory for north they
have been struggling for a long time
they faced the best team in the world
right here the group stage and they make
it work in overtime 1917 but then North
did it again if they get close he is
gonna be able to completely destroy
anybody on long now the noise has been
most affect we have to find three more
but there is this
[Applause]
flashes pollito and the damage until
able to deliver these that you use the
smoke steeply can maybe stay alive a lot
longer blade with that UMP is gonna lay
down ms now and the bombs going with him
this actually is just gonna buy this
time and wait may just all spins around
on a pivot watch that head start
may I present to you your champions of
Dreamhack masters dr. 2018 well guys
that was our list now if you do like
csgo I've got some news for you this
Friday maybe 8th from 2 p.m. to 6 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time we're putting on a
little event we're calling stomp our
squad where you the fans get to play us
from the score eSports in the server and
go toe-to-toe in counter-strike if it
sounds like something you're interested
in tune into the stream or if you want
to play against us email squads at the
score comm with your discord name and
the discord names of all of your party
members and I will see you there there's
one thing I want to show you I used to
be I guess I still am a huge fan of
jean-claude van Damme we got time cop
and Lionheart the teaser says when the
streets are a jungle there can only be
one king
ooh Timecop is sick it's like legit
actually sick turn back the clock and
you're history whoo and Dan man used to
be quite something